Chase is on Twitter, can you explain to me? How using only cash is beneficial?
Well, I don't use only cash
I use I
pay things over the internet all the time, and I use a debit card obviously for that and
I use a debit card at the gas pump and
A few other places here there, here's the thing
Money is weird
There's it it activates
portions of the brain let me give you an example okay in the internet world
Including it Ramsey solutions when we put something on a website
The harder it is for you to buy something the less likely you are to buy it. You won't follow through on the transaction
It's called friction in the internet world
If you got to stand in line at a store
Some people just put the thing down and walk out of the store. That's friction
The harder it is to buy something the less you buy
That's thing one you need to remember now. There is such a thing as emotional friction
Now what I mean by that is this in your mind right now or physically if you want to I'm gonna do it
Take your wallet out if you have one. This is my wallet. I have a money clip
I carry in my front pocket with hundred-dollar bills, so there's a hundred dollar bill, right?
Lay that $100 bill in front of you with Uncle Benjamin Franklin's eyes piercing into your soul
Okay put beside that
Your debit card right?
Put your debit card decided or your credit card beside it now. There's a couple things that happen when you spend the cash
It hurts
It creates emotional friction it activates the pain centers of the brain actually
MIT did a study with MRIs and
They were studying consumer behavior, and when the consumer spends cash
It activates the pain centers of the brain when you make the exact same transaction with plastic
You do not it does not activate the pain centers of the brain you don't feel it
and so you spend more
When you spend with plastic than you do with cash
Tons of studies showing this the average purchase is 12 to 18 percent more that you will spend
In a fast-food setting using plastic you will spend 70% more in a vending machine
in the
hotel lobby
You will spend a hundred and seventy percent more
Double triple the transactions
When you use plastic yeah, I'll take chips and a coke and a candy bar, right
But when you're actually putting these you have to feed that dollar and that thing right
You actually feel that and you spend
way less
So all of that is is emotional friction
You need to be aware of that the other thing that happens is this think about this. Here's what's interesting
Yeah, when you were a kid
If you're if you're an old guy like me you might have traded marbles with your friend
Yeah, marble, and you trade something you were trade something with someone you give them something they give you something
There's an exchange
You hand them something they hand you something see that's what happens when you pay with cash you hand them green presidents faces
They give you the item
Think about what happens with plastic
You give them a piece of plastic
They give you your plastic back
And they give you the item
Isn't it subtle that there was no exchange that occurred
You didn't make a trade you got your plastic back and the item
Because you would never leave the transaction without your own credit card or your own debit card with you, right
Well think about how subtle that is visually and how that activates the brain
So all of that to say that when you spend cash you're more aware of your spending
Here's an example you got to eat
When you're paying cash, and you lay a hundred-dollar bill in that little black tray Uncle Ben's coffin
You know it's his coffin cuz he ain't coming back
You just killed the old boy off. He's gone, right?
Yeah, black tray goes away. You don't ever see Uncle Ben again. He's gone Benjamin Franklin is out of here
But when you send that plastic bout guess what comes back the plastic and you have a tendency to spend more on
Alcohol more on desserts and pick up the other person's tab at the restaurant when you are paying with plastic
Then when you're paying with cash
This is why McDonald's was the first one all these years ago in the fast-food business
to start taking plastic one hours when I first started this show 25 years ago nobody took plastic at all in fast food and
They didn't take it the grocery store either
you wrote a check or you paid cash and fast foods 25 years ago or
You pay cash
you wrote a check or you paid cash and
because it was scary to people to think that people might actually run up debt buying groceries or
Run up debt buying food at a fast food place, but McDonald's changed all of that
And it wasn't long after McDonald's did us. They did a big study on behavior and
And they found that you spend 78 percent more you know I'll supersize that
I'll put fries with that and I'll pay for his two and give me the apple pie
When it's on plastic when it's cash it's like dollar menu, baby
Changes everything
When you spend with cash it
Changes the transaction now all of that is important to think about it think about stuff like Apple pay with your phone
See that's even worse
Because you're not even handing them a form of payment. You're just waving a wand
your phone
You're like freaking Harry Potter buying stuff here. You just waved a wand and got free stuff
That's Apple pay even less
emotional friction
Different methodologies would pay the less emotional friction. There is the more you're gonna spend now our none of this is evil
It's not like that's the mark of the beast. I'm not saying anything like that
But what I am saying is is if you're gonna get control of your money you have to understand
What is being done to you by these companies?
They are
managing your behavior, so
When you spend cash it changes your behavior
Function so especially when someone first starts doing a budget and trying to get out of debt and work the baby steps
I'll put you on a bunch of cash at that point a
bunch of cash I
Still tip with cash
like a valet or
Always leave some cash on the bed as I leave the room and a hotel for the maid because those maids work hard man
You know or if you're gonna tip you tip with cash because you know what you get you get this response like wow?
But if you just include it on your bill nobody even sees it nobody feels it I want the server to be
honored by the trend by the tip
Think about how that works and it'll change the way you look at cash cash is an important part of your financial turnaround